[Jonathan] What's your name?
[Cairo] Cairo Sweet.
- I'm Mr. Miller.
I'm assuming that you
got one of these before.
- I read the whole list.
- Well, there's twelve books
on that list.
- Party hard.
♪ Always said I was
a good kid ♪
- What is an adult?
♪ Always said I had... ♪
I'm eighteen.
♪ ...with words ♪
Languishing in the wilds
of Nowhere, Tennessee.
♪ Don't know how I'll ever
break this curse ♪
[Jonathan] Don't you get scared
walking through those woods?
- I'm the scariest thing
in there.
(Jonathan laughs)
♪ Never knew I could
be speechless ♪
[Jonathan] I want you to
write a short story
in the style of your
favorite author.
- Are you offering me special
treatment, Mr. Miller?
- Well... uh.
[Boris] John here is prepping
her to be his transcendence.
[Beatrice] Is she pretty?
- Oh, she's talented.
- Damn, even worse.
[Winnie] What are you
writing about?
- I'm uninspired. I've
had no achievement.
- Make him love you.
♪ I'll set fire to the
whole place ♪
♪ I don't know how I'll ever ♪
[Cairo] She opened her mouth
to say something,
but the words fell away.
- Why did you write this?
This is inappropriate.
- "Write what you know," is what
you said.
- If you don't rewrite
this, I'll have to fail you.
- I dare you.
♪ I feel down, I feel down,
I feel down, I feel down ♪
- It's like he's been living
in gray scale
and you're the first thing
he's ever seen in color.
♪ I feel down, I feel down,
I feel down ♪
- You are the adult. Show
some responsibility.
- You're my student. And I'm
your teacher. That's all.
♪ Burn it down, burn it down,
burn it down ♪
[Jonathan] If she can convince
them that something happened
between us, I can lose my job.
- That's not all you could lose.
- You're gonna ruin his life.
♪ Burn it down, burn it down,
burn it down ♪
♪ Down, down, down, down, down ♪
[Joyce] In your own words,
how did it start?
♪ Always said I was a good kid ♪